the federal government has abandoned
this important issue that's a national
issue so they're angry and it's going to
come out I'm a mayor Eric Adams and I
saw it I saw it from the good liberals
Eric Adams won't be as bad as Bill
DeBlasio and it was like of course he
was going to be as bad if not worse here
he is and he wanted this place to be a
sanctuary City that's one of the things
he ran on he wanted New York City
nobody's nobody's illegal everybody can
come and get stuff and all that good
stuff uh here he is on the illegal
immigration crisis he's starting to
realize there might be a problem here we
had to do a real job of explaining to
Everyday New Yorkers that the federal
government has abandoned this important
issue that's a national issue so they're
angry and it's going to come out I'm a
mayor mayor yeah no Sherlock you
abandon your duty yes the the federal
government has abandoned their Duty I
agree Biden you want to impeach Biden
over Hunter Biden you could impeach
Biden for not doing one of his again
very few there aren't many things the
president supposed to do protect the
border is one of them that would be to
me the way you want to really get rid of
this guy although he's probably just
going to fall down the stairs any of
these days or usually he falls up the
stairs uh but there he you see he's
trying to Kick the Can out of the bucket
okay oh it's it's the federal
government's well you invited everybody
to your city right why don't we have
them in Florida because D santz was like
you come here we're kicking you out
we're we don't have we're not a
sanctuary State we're not a sanctuary
City now watch this this is this might
be the most incredible video of all of
2023 Eric Adams two days ago went on
some local show and they're asking him
about you know what what this whole year
has been like listen to his answer this
is so unbelievable I honestly I thought
this was AI the first time I saw it this
is just incredible this is real enjoy Mr
Mayor we've come to the end of what was
a very eventful 2023 right so when you
look at the totality of the year if you
had to describe it and it's tough to do
in one word what would that word be and
tell me why uh New York uh this is a
place where every every day you wake up
uh you could experience everything from
a plane crashing into our Trade Center
to a a person who's celebrating a new
business that's open uh this is a very
very complicated City and that's why
it's the greatest City on the
globe can't do this my
fugger what first off New York is two
words let's just put that aside for a
second uh I was in New York City during
911 um the planes crashing was not one
of the greatest things about the city it
was probably I don't it might have
literally been the worst day of my life
I mean it was was it was UN an
unimaginable tragedy and all of those
things but like what kind of insane
statement is that sum up the year in one
word New York oh continue planes are
crashing into the Trade Center someone
opened up a pizza shop these people it's
like it brains have been broken broken I
don't know how to overstate that enough
people's brains are actually broken and
this man has invited all of this into
New York city so again if you live in
New York City and we show you migrants
that come in that are flown in from
Phoenix as we just showed you and then
thrown into the streets of New York City
and now there's
110,000 of them in New York City and the
city is stressed and so many people
think of the amount every single person
watching this every single person
watching this knows somebody that has
fled New York City or the greater New
York area since Co right so all of these
people they took their businesses out
they took they took their it's not just
the businesses and the money and the tax
dollars and all that you're taking all
of the good functional people out so
then you're left with less functional
people less productive people less
people that pay into the system but
again it's not just about money it's
about the culture around all that and
the system is stressed and crime is up
and drugs are up and all of the stuff so
what is going on uh with the federal
government though because I Eric Adams
is right to I suppose to some degree the
federal government has been negligent in
their Duty uh when it comes to uh wait
do we have something else here before I
move on thr what do we got again oh
we're gonna watch it one more time we're
gonna I mean it's just it's incredible
they want me to watch it again oh to
describe it and it's tough to do in one
word what would that word be and tell me
why uh New York uh this is a place where
every day you wake up uh you could
experience everything from a plane
crashing into our Trade Center to a a
person who's celebrating a new business
that's open
what bro what are you talking about
man bro I'm out man I see what you guys
did there okay okay uh but again Eric
Adams to give the devil his due he is
right to some degree from the earlier
clip which is that the federal
government has been negligent I'm the
mayor man what do you want me to do I
always put on my well-fitting
suit